(light music)
- Strange time to practice.
But better late than never.
I swear, I'm not a stalker.
I just really had to talk to you.
- How'd you find me?
- Do you even have to ask?
- Elsa tracks my phone.
- First off, it sucks you're avoiding me.
I put myself out there
and I was honest with you.
And for that, I get the silent treatment?
Even if you don't feel the same,
you could at least be
there for me as a friend.
You're making me feel crazy.
Honestly, if I knew that
you were gonna be all weird
and that this was gonna
jeopardize our friendship,
I never in a million years
would've told you how I felt.
Because it is becoming incredibly clear
that you don't feel the same way.
("I Think We're Alone Now")
♪ Children behave ♪
♪ That's what they say
when we're together ♪
♪ Watch how you play ♪
♪ They don't understand ♪
♪ And so we're running
just as fast as we can ♪
♪ Holding on to one another's hands ♪